thirty thousand tons of corn this ship
could have been the last to leave
Ukrainian ports if Russia hadn't agreed
to extend the deal to allow vital grain
deliveries The Pact brokered by the U.N
and turkey in Istanbul last summer allow
safe export of Ukrainian and Russian
produced through Black Sea to the world
markets a joint coordination center with
representatives from the three countries
and the U.N was set up in Istanbul to
oversee the shipments the importance of
the Black Sea initiative and the
parallel memorandum of understanding
between the U.N and the Russian
Federation is clear
these agreements matter for Global Food
security
Ukrainian and Russian products feed the
worlds the initiative has enabled the
safe shipment of about 30 million tons
of crops since July 2022 and helped
alleviate the global food crisis
aggravated by moscow's invasion of
Ukraine one of the world's leading grain
exporters
the duration of the latest extension was
about to end with the efforts of our
country and the support of our Russian
and Ukrainian friends it is agreed that
the Black Sea grain Corridor will be
extended for two months
the deal is now safe for two more months
but lack of coordination between Ukraine
and Russia blunt its Effectiveness there
is a chance not in words but in Deeds to
help ensure Global Food security and
first of all to help the countries that
need it the most secondly our
fundamental assessments of the Istanbul
agreements of July 22 2022 have not
changed and the distortions of their
implementation should be corrected as
quickly as possible Cube accuses Moscow
of deliberate the interrupting export
inspections while Moscow maintains that
hurdles to their shipments have not been
removed despite the fact that their
grains and fertilizers are immune from
Western sanctions the grain deal was
extended once more after difficult talks
between concerned parties and after
Russia had threatened to Withrow but
moscow's refusal to a longer extension
is an indication that the crucial
agreement is still fragile synonym solo
Al Jazeera stumble